my hand comes up boom
[Music]
okay I'm going to work on distillation
me so I'm going to take this strikeout
and I didn't have my weight shifting oh
my oh wait
for your ideal type so I'm on his neck
my head
next up I'll make him get to the horse -
okay and I'm going to ease up on the
elbow our cuddle on the inner coil
conscious but we want to stop doing this
part we're going to lead with that part
of the weapon and you're going to hit
right there okay so very snappy
boom got it okay and then I want you to
feel what that's why okay we're done
your video right here okay so you want
to get a wave of benefit is that I don't
want to hit here because then I can't do
the follow up but when I hear my kidding
[Music]
don't
this is work on the Body Geometry don't
worry about this track yet but if you
move far away I'm not using it to take
them off balance and nobody pull it that
would be a clash right so I'm turning
inside with us I knew it might be we get
the hounds and just think about that you
see that oh if I do the other one look
at the range what happened to my elbow
on an all psyche the shorter it is to
water the more powerful this is more
right then this moves look more to hit
at the initial tilt up in the bottom you
see that not in the choreographic a
Miata Mike so here
inside fool kick-starts treat every okay
just now
on this inside inside okay I'm not doing
that
this shoulder I turned it away that
we've had it's not moving
you see but I'm turning you see you see
wait but I'm not going forward is none
other weapon is jammed
sweet spot right here
we're save your company Elmo
this is just a lot
[Music]
if you take you will be underneath so I
did the energy there's not much I can do
about that
okay so he's gonna take care of that now
as he comes in he creates space if I
rolled on my hip on the spinning head
entire time by body moves you see here
going to strike I'm not even underneath
it
do you understand I do not go around
that head you are rolling around that
gap because you're not doing the initial
prescribed energy strangles
we should were supposed to come in at
his legs okay
this is not what I knew it okay so now
that shoulder is we're gonna make it go
that high this is not the face yet okay
and I'm doing everything and you're on
the start a million miles away
did you see where your heating at the
very end the public making gravitational
marriage nothing why would he be there
why are we there now what is the
prescribed energy drink push the push
it's a wire me down there so you can do
it again azúcar crushing my face
that's where his donkey energy is
required me to go okay but on the first
thing here here's the push he deviates
do what you as you don't do that so he
cuts my arm now you know you can't
expect you can't confuse a giddy job of
reconciliation training with a tactical
aspect they're not always to say okay so
I cannot wait for
I take this long so we're all standing
now and he throws this right right
[Music]
let's go I'm doing it here like this
it's not it's not this right
remember he goes right whoa it's it's
all that power that I have so I start
school with things looking to push
elbows I write I'm hitting him with my
phone phone so I'm starting to see this
now you're like you're late lifesaver
hampire its power steep you Paulo your
power seat okay so I will quote he
pushes on it I didn't have it you see I
didn't now let's push it on you'll find
using techniques you want but the nice
box you try to displace me on the first
one I just need you for our mini coup de
let's go
first time Oh in her mouth then she
pushes from there that's what we do
right she shared Plus no but we don't do
that because it pushes you get
if he goes back to the far right there
you go
this part is not like this bark too much
this part here but this part doesn't
boom
do you see the difference and now now
you're gonna come in from there right
[Music]
so okay so here's what we're seeing now
okay right check it then we do the next
part and I yield